What else is Dwayne looking to do?
What else do you want to do from a
creative standpoint in the business
today? Outside of you and I doing
something big. Right?
Outside of that? I know you want that.
You ain't got to say it. I do want
that. Yeah. So you ain't got to say, I
know that. So don't say that like I
already know that answer.
So take me out the box.
What else are you looking to do?
From a space of creative in the
business of entertainment with you on
the screen, is there anything specific
that you feel you haven't done?
Or are you looking to just figure it out
as you go?
Well, figuring out as we go.
Uh, that works sometimes I think, for
guys like you and I.
But also you want to make sure that
you're sharp and focused. So I would
say there's things out there that I
haven't done. There's genres that I
haven't worked in yet that might
include some song that might include
some choreography.
Nice. It might include.
But who would do it? There's- What do
you mean, in what way?
You say it would include song and
choreography. So, you wouldn't be in
that, of course. So who would do it?
Why do you say it like
That though?
What do you mean? You can't dance.
As if.
As if I can't dance.
What are you talking about?
You can't dance. I can Boogie oogie
oogie.
What are you talking. What is that?
What is Boogie Oogie oogie?
Are you 78?
What is that? I'll show you later.
The f*** just happened.
Who'd I turn into?
He can boogie Oogie.
"I'll Boogie oogie oogie". What?
The f*** are you talking about?
Why you got to
Say it like that? Like it ain't gonna
be you.
No, I like that.
That's actually a great space.
A great space play. What about drama?
I mean, it's that. It's drama.
It's really. It's.
It continues to be everything and
anything. Okay. Because at the end of
the day, I got into this business years
ago, just like you got into this
business years ago.
We had our critics.
We had our cynics.
Oh, another comedian trying to make it
in Hollywood. Oh, and another
professional wrestler trying to make it
in Hollywood. No blueprint ahead of us.
So all of a sudden, years later, here
we are. And I just I love being in this
position that, you know, knock on wood,
you know, we come in, we can greenlight
movies, we can greenlight projects, and
they could be in any genre we choose
to. But at the end of the day, most
important thing, taking care of the
audience.
I like the fact that you still embrace
those that are coming along in the
journey. You still shake their hands.
You still make the eye contact.
That's the biggest pace or peace.
For me. It's like the respect.
You respect the business, you respect
the people. And I think that's why your
wins will continue to come.